[Music]
see these trees
they know what's gonna happen they know
someone's gone down first time I saw
mark Putnam I thought he looked like a
picture in a magazine but things go
wrong his things will those are
prescription you got a prescription for
a thousand percocet that's the way the
devil comes she comes just everything
you've ever wanted
I mean I solve a big case I was a bank
robber in Derry he's not 11 banks in
four months
Susan help me bring down this bank
robber I'd be taking a hell of a big
risk big risk pay big money
he lives with us we did it didn't we we
deserve her Award
you are the only thing that makes me
Riley dude nice dad hey sweetheart
we got him congratulations
ain't nothing good gonna come of that
mess around on that goddamn federal cop
where's miss Densham boyfriend's house
you come in here I'll bite your [ __ ]
dick
[Music]
why didn't you go I have a job I have a
family but I'd needed you I've seen
somebody burn down my house last night
you don't blame me baby I got six grand
here for you I don't want to see you
anymore I know way to treat your start
right
snitch
did you go to pregnant
[Music]
[Music]